we've seen many an example of how the
female bathrooms in public buildings
have been made into the non-binary and
the men's have remained the men's and
that's outrageous discrimination isn't
it yeah we we normally call this
indirect discrimination so this is what
looks like a neutral rule they've
converted some of the toilets into
gender neutral toilets but it actually
has a dis proportionately negative
effect on one group over another and
actually in this context if you had kept
the men's toilets the same and had
converted the women's toilets only and
the reasons that you can imagine someone
would be thinking about with this would
be well we want cubicles we don't want
to have to deal with urinal so it's
easier if we just convert the the spaces
that have already just got cubicles and
that's sail into account for the fact
that what you've done there is you've
treated women less favorably than you've
treated men because you've removed um
something from them and you've not
removed it from men so it could be
direct discrimination in that context